[Music]
sister cassandra james is saying what
day was the ceremonial sabbath held
the ceremonial sabbath was held on the
15th day of the first month
look at verse
15 of leviticus 23
and on the 15th day of the same month is
the feast of unleavened bread unto the
lord seven days you must eat eleven
bread in the first day which is the
first of the seven
you shall have in holy convocation you
shall do no service therein but he shall
offer an offering made by fire to the
lord seven days in the seventh day is
unholy convocation he shall do no
certified work therein so the seven days
of unleavened bread celebration began
the day after passover and that first
day which was the 15th was considered a
sabbath and the seventh was also
considered a sabbath